ich weiß nicht ob dir das bewusst ist
was das hier sein könnte lose lose
Gewinne Gewinne Gewinne genau und das
ist das fragen-lotto jetzt kannst du
aber selber entscheiden in einem
gewissen Maße welche Fragen du gestellt
werden bekommst gestellt die gestellt
werden und zwar die roten sind
unverschämte Fragen und die Grünen haben
wie viele soll es denn sein wie du
möchtest dann machen wir jeweils eine
oder ne das ist zu wenig achso okay ich
dachte
sonst ist so man macht bestimmte Fragen
die liebt man sehr die möchte hast du
die formuliert wir zusammen Antworten
du bist du warst teilweise gleichzeitig
Polizist und Comedian leidest du in
einer multiple Persönlichkeitsstörung
ich habe gehört schizophren
Volksmund aber ist es ist einfach ganz
anders das was anderes der hat ja genau
nein ich ähm an einer
Persönlichkeitsstörung würde ich nicht
sagen ist das ich bin ich profitiere an
einer multiplin ähm
Persönlichkeitsbildung vielleicht könnte
man sagen also es war sogar Teil
tatsächlich so witzig ich bin habe mir
jemand habe ich eine festgenommen ich
habe ihn kontrolliert irgendwie so unter
meine Sachen habe ich sie nicht im
quatschen
so also aber ich bin damit ich will ja
aber das ist kein genau aber das ist
normal ja aber ich kann auch anders so
und das war auch alles gut klar gekommen
ich müsste jetzt eigentlich zu Hause
sitzen Programm schreiben aber jetzt
muss ich hier festnehmen ja
gut aber das war halt gut ich meine das
mit dem einen habe ich ja noch Geld
verdient im Prinzip das war mein
Lebensunterhalt das andere war ein
erster Linie
anfangt
das musste ich äh das muss ich noch
nicht nein aber es ist jeder darf
jemanden du darfst genau man darf man
darf sozusagen bis zum Eintreffen der
Polizei jemand tatsächlich ähm
wichtige Erkenntnisse jeder darf viel
wichtiger kennen Sie hier drauf immer
die Polizei kommt warum dann einfach so
ist mein recht
gut okay so machen wir was harmloses ja
genau Grün das sind die Fragen die
stellen
bist du ein Naturtalent
würde ich jetzt ganz ehrlich von mir
selber natürlich nie behaupten es gibt
allerdings in meinem Umfeld eine ganze
Menge Leute die das bejahen würden
andere Frage ist das direkt angekommen
was du gemacht hast weil ich kenne viele
Kabarettisten die habe ich vor zehn 15
20 Jahren gesehen da war das grauenhaft
ja alt herrenwitze und was und die sind
so richtig mit den Jahren in die Spur
gekommen bis zur Genialität ähm
Moment also mehr ich würde nicht sagen
dass ich genial war aber es war Gott sei
Dank so dass sie tatsächlich schon von
Anfang an gelacht haben ich habe
natürlich auch da Rückschläge alleine
müssen und manche Dinge kommen dann
einfach nicht so an ähm es macht aber
natürlich auch den den Anspruch also es
macht es auch anstrengende und und
herausfordernd aber natürlich der
Anspruch entsprechend schnell steigt
weißt du jeder der dich sieht mit einem
mit dem ersten Programm was irgendwie
gut ankommt ich habe in Berlin gespielt
sechs Wochen lang irgendwie ähm 5 Tage
genau ausverkauft ich meine war gut dann
gehen 100 Leute rein aber wenn du das
hochrechnet 5 Tage die Woche 6 Wochen
lang da kommt schon ein bisschen was
zusammen ja und und das als die Bühne
quasi als allererstes Bühnenprogramm war
schon nicht so schlecht und
dementsprechend natürlich auch der
Anspruch weil viele erwarten okay es
wird mindestens mindestens genauso gut
wenn ich noch besser ja
also auch immer leicht
gemacht
gefällt mir einfach
ist deine Zeit als Polizist kein dunkles
Kapitel in deiner Biografie überhaupt
nicht ja weil zum einen zehre ich davon
und und verwerte es halt auf der Bühne
zum anderen habe ich diesen Beruf
tatsächlich auch gerne aus geübt und
habe wie wir sehr vorhin schon
besprochen haben ja auch eine ich glaube
eine ganz gute Einstellung dazu gehabt
von daher stehe ich dazu und ich fühle
mich auch immer noch nach wie vor
damit ja wie soll man sagen irgendwo
verbunden so passiert sie nicht du sitzt
an der Goldenen Kamera neben dir
irgendein Megastar und was haben Sie
denn so Feuer gemacht Polizist
äh das mag das magst durchaus sein aber
dann ist es eher ein Armutszeugnis was
ich derjenige ausstellt so oder so also
von daher also ich stehe dazu sagen ich
ich ich werde würde das nie
verheimlichen ähm und ich stehe dazu
aber eben weil ich weil ich doch sagen
kann ich habe war denke ich mal waren
ganz anständiger Kopf so ja anständige
Kopf
es ist die Frage wie du willst
was machen
wann hast du endlich deine Schulden
abbezahlt
was die Frage
das wird noch ein paar Jahre dauern ja
das wird noch ein paar Jahre
gebraucht mit allem drum und dran
ich arbeite ich arbeite daran ich hoffe
dass es irgendwann überhaupt mal so sein
wird könnte die Frage sein
am liebsten würdest du der deutsche
James Bond werden und meinst allein ein
Haus bauen zu können aber sonst noch
alles klar also das mit dem Haus ich
habe es sogar also ich habe es nicht
komplett selbstgemachte Garage habe ich
komplett selbst gebaut ja vom Mauerwerk
Dachstuhl alles komplett Programm und im
Haus sehr sehr viel gemacht also ich bin
schon so ein leidenschaftlicher
Handwerker und ansonsten alles klar man
muss natürlich auch Ziele ab und zu hoch
stecken das Ziel wirklich wirklich
geschafft das glaube ich nicht ich würde
versuchen jedenfalls ein guter sein dann
kommt glaube ich die Frage die Du nee
das war die Arbeit
damit
meinst du dass du wirklich lustig bist
du weißt es nicht ich weiß es nicht ich
hoffe ich hoffe dass die Leute lachen
nicht weil sie gestört sind oder Mitleid
haben sondern weil es wirklich lustig
finden und das würde bedeuten dass ich
lustig sein kann ich kann aber auch
meine Frau wird euch bestätigen nicht
immer nur lustig sein aber wo ich bin
Mensch wie eine andere ja aber ich
glaube schon dass ich grundsätzlich
lustig Kerlchen bin gut dann viel Erfolg